president trump issuing a full pardon
for michael flynn his former national
security adviser
trump tweeted quote it is my great honor
to announce that general michael t
flynn has been granted a full pardon
congratulations to general flynn and his
wonderful family
i know you will now have a truly
fantastic thanksgiving
flynn had pled guilty in 2017 to lying
in the fbi in the early stages of the
russia
investigation i.e hoax um
so geraldo i i believe that this is
great news i know you feel the same way
because we know he was entrapped
by a group of people out for a trump
scalp
and he was just happened he was a victim
of circumstances
that's me well i don't know about that i
don't know about the circumstances but
bravo president trump you did exactly
the right thing
general flynn was a great soldier in
afghanistan
and in iraq uh he became very political
i get that i get that he uh he rubbed
some people the wrong way because he was
a political activist
but this whole thing with kislyak the
russian ambassador and those
conversations he had
he knew kislyak they'd been in moscow
they had been in washington dc together
he's just chatting them up hey be cool
we're cool you're cool
uh and for uh the fbi to come to the
white house and
and uh to entrap him uh greg you're
exactly right it was entrapment
uh they went there to get him it was a
perjury trap
you know they asked them a question that
they knew that he couldn't answer
without embarrassing himself
and then they parlayed that they said
they wanted either to fire get him fired
or get him arrested and because of their
their greedy anti-trump hatred uh with
the hope
bureau was turned by mueller into this
revenge squad
uh to get trump uh flynn was just
collateral damage greg
yeah you know dana and the other thing
that was bothersome is this judge
sullivan who
uh refused i guess to uh grant a
dismissal even though
pretty much everybody was on the same
page right so what happened
as i understand it judges are very
reluctant to overturn things
when you had somebody that pled guilty
originally then he wanted to change his
plea
but then you had the justice department
say we're cool with him changing his
plea
so then the judge uh sullivan he has
just dragged this out for about six
months
and i know that you know i'm sure that
michael flynn and his lawyer and his
family would have preferred a dismissal
because that means we we there's nothing
on your record there's nothing now a
full pardon means also
that he has a full pardon but i do think
that a dismissal
would have been better but given that
the judge wasn't granting that that the
pardon was given
um and now that case is moot in front of
the judge
moot i love that word great word it's a
great word i'll remind people if
anybody's upset about the michael flynn
thing
remember who president obama pardoned an
f-a-l-n terrorist who was responsible
for something like 100 bombings
uh will this is the first time i've
asked you a question in maybe 10 years
back in the days of red eye
you have definitely cleaned up i have to
say
thank you yes what are your thoughts on
any other pardons you can talk about
flynn but do you do you see other
pardons coming up
well we'll see about other pardons let
me talk about flynn if i might
um adam schiff has talked about the
president's pardoning process being
something akin to organized crime what
would organize crime look like it would
look like bringing
all the levers of power onto a single
individual using extortion
to break that person both judicially
legislatively
and financially and all of that is what
happened to michael flynn he's broke
the justice department originally the
court system his own lawyers the fbi
all levered against this one single
individual to see this man receive a
pardon is honestly an
act of justice maybe to dana's point he
might have gotten dismissal but this is
the only guaranteed
path to justice for michael flynn that
he very much deserves at this moment
so emily i'm going to ask you a kind of
a curveball question
so be prepared i hope you are prepared
you are a lawyer
um a question was asked in the cavuto
hour whether uh uh donald
trump should pardon himself and the
person who was answering the question it
might have been karl rove said no that
would make him look guilty
and i'm thinking to myself that the
people that are saying they're going to
go after trump don't even have
a crime to charge him right so it's like
he should pardon himself because they're
going to go after him and then
find the charge so wouldn't you tell
trump
yeah you should pardon yourself because
these people are coming after you
without even a crime
uh greg i like your style i think that's
a really creative
move for him in the form of messaging
npr but legally
it's moot to use one of your favorite
words because without a crime without a
conviction
there's nothing to pardon so if i can as
well speak to this
the story to me you guys it's not the
flynn pardon
it's the reason the pardon was necessary
and just taking it a step further
from you talking about judge sullivan
you guys he sat on
an uncontested department of justice
motion to dismiss for almost
seven months now we know that the
incoming administration has pledged
not to use the doj to wield it like a
weapon but i hope that includes
conducting an audit of the judiciary and
holding responsible these kinds of
errant
judges that are clearly political
activists
and you know me i'm not usually a
fear-monger but this to me was
absolutely
absurd and he truly tried to
circumnavigate the justice system
so i hope moving forward that at least
we see some of these judges being held
responsible
excellent you know dana um i know he's
gonna pardon more people
i'm putting out the name of lil kim
what did lil kim do uh she was she went
to jail
because she refused to snitch on her
friends i think she got a year for
lying to um uh the the
who who you ever lied to in court who's
that person the judge the judge yeah i'm
a
yeah i'm pretty much a law-abiding
person but it was it happened at a
shootout back in like 2001.
so i i and i think that trump should do
it before the grammys
because she did win a grammy for the uh
lady marmalade
uh remake i love that trump did this
then little kim can go to the grammys
and thank donald trump
at the grammys i know you're watching
great ideas it is a great idea pardon
kim
okay joe biden don't pardon that one
other person
no you don't do not do it i know
you're sick i know what you're saying
don't do it wouldn't it just drive
people crazy if he did pardon
okay bill can yeah i'm for pardoning
little kim great
okay do not pardon that other person all
right not big ed
joe michael grimm the congressman from
staten island oh there you go
that's not bad all right